on va rejoindre le père fouras et
olivier minne
regardez bien parce que je vous le dis
on mettra enora on passe partout après
dedans voilà c'est important qu'ils
aient toute l'équipe de fort boyard
qu'il le fasse julien alors donc vous
allez poser des énigmes à olivier minne
qui va tourner il va devoir répondre à
des énigmes
pendant qu'il tournait à chaque fois
qu'ils n'étaient que se retrouver
nous donnerons d euros une sautée nauges
merci je n'y reviens pas défis qu alors
est ce qu'on peut faire tourner et
olivier minne est ce qu'on peut avoir un
petit peu plus de sous sur le plateau je
vous avais en régime
rien de secondes vous faites c'est bon
c'est régler le son je savais que
c'était pas du tout et je connais un
petit peu alors ça va olivier et que
tout moment ça va ça va aller si
monsieur a faites vous plaisir à
survivre mais surtout je n'avais pas
pour moi elles font le tour des
continents on les grave y difficilement
mais ce l'est tenir c'est quand même
beaucoup rire qui sautent le lit et me
suit rien compris
des continents on les grave y
difficilement mais ce l'est tenir c'est
quand même beaucoup rire
qui sont-elles elles font tourner
continent c'est peut-être de boeuf aussi
à de boeuf l'onglet non nous allons dire
la côte le co peut te la corde
d'autres au sein ce qui entoure le
levant torex le thorax du marais je suis
content aux commandes auraient sorola de
boeuf à l'âge où je viens là que la dent
en or car au musée moi je commente
toujours une côte de boeuf mais nokia se
mettant les mains sur le haut niveau
français d'y aller quand on compte les
contrats miniers bravo
jules a choisi quant à 200 on notera 200
euros alesi de sauvons nous retrouver à
grimer passage des programmes olivier
avant on m'apprend parfois pour une
chipeau lorsqu'on fait des amalgames une
chanson à magloire les muscles et un
composé de catherine dupin du couscous
on peut me déguster qui est l aide du
pikes connu qu'est ce qu'on peut manger
avec du pain et du couscous des
boulettes non chose que les boulettes
qu'est-ce qu'on peut manger elle ajouté
elle est longue
elle est longue elle est mince quelques
bateaux vers la merguez muguet
oh la la
c'est pareil
arrêtez arrêtez monsieur mais arrêtez
arrêt olivier ça va olivier ça va c'est
bien olivier salamin olivier écoutent
mieux ce serait trop olé olé il vient
nous rejoindre à l'instant on y vient et
on embrasse aussi bien gignac qui va
venir je sais pas c'est ma vouloir le
faire